[Música]
había una vez una niña
sonriente alegre
alborotada
esta niña tenía 8 años y estaba de
vacaciones en un club
tenía un short un polo
esta niña tenía dos particularidades
una que era gordita
y la otra que tenía el pelo rapado
coco pelado desean
tuvo un contagio de piojos y a su mamá
se le ocurrió la brillante idea de
apagarlo
esa mañana
estaban jugando en la cancha de fútbol
hermanos primos amigos
a ella le tocó cerrar que era
y en el momento en que estaba ahí
pendiente esperando la pelota
le meten un gol por la uach
y un señor que pasaba por ahí le grita
por la guata borno
por la guasa gordo
fue el lema de la familia
todos reían a carcajadas cada vez que lo
recordaban
incluso la niña
reía sonrojada
esa niña
fui yo
y ahí entendí
porque mi mamá me llegó al médico
porque tenía que hacer dieta con tan
corta edad
entendí que el sobrepeso
era un problema
y que yo no debía tenerlo
y como quería que me acepten que me
quieran
entonces hacia la dieta estricta
tenía que
obedecer
quizás ahí comenzó el mandato de tener
que ser perfecto
todos tenemos un cuerpo herido
si todos
un cuerpo herido
constituido por todas aquellas
experiencias traumáticas
caracterizada por el rechazo
o el castigo
este cuerpo
está lleno de dolor
de miedo
consiste en todas estas heridas
que no se ven
heridas de abandono de traición de
injusticia de humillación
que inconscientemente
que están nuestros padres o cuidadores
y lo que hace nuestra personalidad
para poder protegernos
es ponernos máscaras
armaduras
para no sentir el dolor de la herida
estas máscaras pueden ser la del control
desde la perfección la de ser buenos y
amorosos
la que nos hace huir
o depender de otros
todas estas máscaras
requieren de mucha energía para poder
sostenerlas
y si no le hacemos a tiempo
pueden causar dolores corporales o
enfermedad
y qué pasa con el deseo
bueno
también tenemos un cuerpo prohibido
dónde está toda la represión del deseo
donde se encuentran todos esos mandatos
creencias pensamientos tabúes
que no son aceptados por la familia
por nuestra sociedad
y que terminan convirtiéndose en dolor
terminan convirtiéndose en deseo
exacerbado
o en convulsiones
como la compulsión a la acción entonces
tengo que hacer hacer hacer nunca tengo
tiempo para nada
o la compulsión a sentir entonces como
en exceso
como bebidas
alcohólicas exceso
consumo drogas
todo para sentir
para poder disfrutar de la vida
y yo me puse varias máscaras para poder
sobrevivir a este mundo
una de ellas la de intentar ser perfecta
tenía que sobresalir
tenía que obedecer
siempre la estrellita
pero con una sonrisa
siempre una actitud positiva
pero además
tenía que tener éxito
siempre trabajé en áreas comerciales
primero en la industria farmacéutica
luego en medios de comunicación
y tenía que sobresalir tenía que lograr
ser reconocida
por eso me puse la meta de ser gerente
comercial
y lo logré
pero
que tuve que entregar
que tenemos que entregar
que tenemos que entregar para ser
reconocidos
yo
tuve que dejar a un lado mis relaciones
de pareja
a mis hijos a mi familia
a mis amigos
todo lo que más quería
nunca tenía tiempo para nada
en un momento de mi vida
todo se debe un bajo me quedé sin nada
y ahí
ahí comenzó mi camino de crecimiento
personal
y ahí fue donde poder reconocerme
donde puede ver mis sombras todo aquello
que me causa rechazo
vergüenza culpa
pero también descubrí mis luces
esa
soy yo ahora
catherine plaza
life coach coach transpersonal profesora
de danza prima e instructora de
meditación
pero lo más importante
es que encontré el propósito de mi vida
qué es acompañar a otros
a entrar dentro de ellos mismos
para poder sentir
para poder sanar
para poder vivir en plenitud
y ese es mi camino ahora
pero quizás lo más importante
lo que realmente me ayudó a fortalecer
todo este proceso
fue la pandemia
porque a muchos no nos dio la
oportunidad de escapar de ir hacia
afuera el estar encerrados hizo que
fuéramos hacia adentro
hacia nuestras emociones
y muchos no las reconocen
entonces empezamos a sentir el miedo
la tristeza la rabia
emociones que generalmente son
rechazadas
y no sabíamos qué hacer con eso
de repente se convirtieron en estrés en
ansiedad en depresión
reconocer nuestras emociones
es poder sentirla es poder
vivirla en carne viva
espero permanecer ahí
sin el drama de la mente
sin la cháchara de los pensamientos
entrar
y sentir
y de repente
se disuelve
sola poco a poco sin darnos cuenta
simplemente desaparece
nos hemos encontrado
con la muerte
no solo de personas queridas
también con la fragilidad
algunos entendimos que la vida
simplemente se puede ir
no depende de nosotros
no la controlamos
así como nuestro corazón no depende de
que leíamos el late
simplemente lo hace
pero también tenemos un cuerpo cósmico
es importante saberlo
es un cuerpo
interior que reconoce nuestra esencia
y nuestro ser
es el cuerpo de la sensibilidad
con todos sus misterios
es el cuerpo de la introspección la
meditación la respiración pero también
la de la caricia la del abrazo la de la
pasión
la que nos conecta con el cielo y la
tierra
pero también con el otro
esta integración es la que me ayudó a
pasar de la niña herida
la que quería
complacer a los demás
a una mujer adulta
responsable
de mis procesos
de mis emociones
de mis pensamientos mis palabras mis
acciones
es intencional
esa mujer
ayuda a esa niño
a darle amor
a que no se sienta más sola
a que no necesita vivir en el dolor
porque puede enfrentarlo porque ya no
les necesita ya creció
ya crece y por eso ya no necesito
manipular
y acepto la liga
y como es
sabiendo que hay algo más grande que me
sostiene
la vida
si tu cuerpo
ha gritado
ha llorado
ha sentido culpa y vergüenza como el mío
aclamado amor aceptación
sanación
es importante que sepas que en ese
cuerpo
está nuestro corazón
y que puede
haber pasado por grietas
dolores
rupturas
puede estar parchado
siempre siempre
va a tener amor
entonces
que clama a tu cuerpo